tim welcome back to computer files
slightly different circumstances we were
doing
mega fave numbers in the last one right
that's right yes
i was talking about my favorite number
um which many people were disappointed i
didn't know by heart
um but it is still my favorite topic to
talk about
big numbers um in the video i mentioned
uh prime numbers in particular and the
big number i selected
for that video was a prime number and i
said i'll come back and talk about how
they relate to computer science
prime numbers in computer science are
interesting for various reasons
one of them is it's not always easy to
find whether something is a prime number
or not and if i
give you a number not like 91 can you
instantly tell whether it's a prime
number or not
um then again if i tell you that 7 times
13 is 91 you can quite quickly verify
that that's right
and therefore 91 is not a prime number
um so there's various shortcuts that
people found
to quickly be able to determine whether
something is a prime number
but no one has found a shortcut
to be able to find the actual prime
factors
so telling that 91 is not a prime number
is fairly easy for a computer to do
finding the number 7 and 13
is relatively difficult of course i say
relatively here because for a computer
it's peanuts to find seven and thirteen
um so that makes it interesting for
computer science
um but what makes it even more
interesting is its application
its application is mostly in
cryptography
if i want to communicate in secret with
you
then i want to be able to do that so one
example of where prime numbers are used
in cryptography
is the diffie-hellman key exchange which
is something that
mike pound was spoke about about three
years ago on this channel
a very interesting video watch it but
another important application that uses
prime numbers is
rsa which stands for revest
shamir edelman the three developers of
the algorithm
and it's heavily based on prime numbers
we see rsa
everywhere don't we it's connecting to
the internet we are almost always using
rsa at some point is that would i be
right in saying that
exactly right yes thank you um
so public key cryptography is the
general class that rsa is in there was a
video about this
a long time ago by robert miles and he
explains what public key crypto
is but one of the most important modern
applications
i would say crucial to the internet is
the fact that https
is built on top of this kind of
technology
now there are two main flavors to
implement it there's rsa
which is the older more established
algorithm
and there's elliptic curve cryptography
again a topic of a different video and
those are basically the two competing
algorithms and of the two rsas based on
prime numbers which is why i'm talking
about those today
in fact i would like to give a
quick demonstration of how rsa is used
by going to our university's website so
the browser i'm using is firefox
but all browsers will have this
functionality what you can see is this
little
padlock in the top left next to the
address
which means that your connection is
secure now you can actually
investigate how the connection is set up
by clicking on the padlock
clicking on the right buttons and then
here's a button that says more
information
and then there's the option to view the
certificate which is what we're going to
do now
and here we see information about these
certificates and the relevant
information that i want to talk about
is right here public key info and so it
says the algorithm is
rsa which is the algorithm i want to
talk about
it says something about the key size
being 2048 bits
then it says exponent which is roughly
65 000
and then there is this number which is
the modulus which is a massive number
it's cut off here
in hexadecimal and if we translate this
to a decimal number the number we end up
with
is this number so what you end up with
is this 600 digit decimal number
it's a massive number and it's not a
prime number actually
but it is the product of two very very
large prime numbers
and two 300 digit prime numbers
now the idea is that nobody knows what
these two prime numbers are
if you can figure out what these two big
300 digit prime numbers are that make up
this larger number i will offer you a
fully funded phd
and a guaranteed spot in the newspapers
and
perhaps even a big prize here and there
and on top of that you get to hack the
nottingham website
but how come then this idea that it's
difficult to find prime factors actually
lays the foundation
for a cryptographic protocol in order to
explain how it works we need to talk
about a slightly different topic first
it's called modular arithmetic now it
sounds complicated but it's actually
very easy
in fact we do it every day if we're
using an analog clock
because a clock every 12 hours it goes
back to its original position
so if i ask you what is 15 hours on the
clock
you will know it's three hours because
it's the remainder
after division by 12. we do it often for
24 hour to 12 hour clock conversions
but you can even do things like minus
one hour which would be
11 on the clock or 25 hours which would
be
one on the clock now the clock we are
going to be talking about is not a 12
hour clock
but a 91 hour clock because 91 is
the product of the two prime numbers
we're interested in the magic
that actually happens is that if you
think
of a magic number between
0 and 90 then
i can instruct you to take that number
and raise it to the fifth
power so can you think of any number
should we go for let's go for number 18.
okay 18.
so what i instruct you to do is to take
the number 18
raise it to the fifth power but do that
on a 91 hour clock
so this is like 18 times 80 five times
and then so it will always be a number
between
0 and 90. for a human this is a bit
complicated i don't expect you to know
the answer
but the answer will be 44 which is you
know it's a normal number between 0 and
19.
and then what i do is i take that number
44 and i raise it to the 29th power
so i multiply it with itself 29 times
on the clock and the number i end up
with is
18. so i know in normal arithmetic you
have this idea of inverse operations is
that a bit like that have we got back to
the start doing that
yes that's exactly right so 29 is a
magical number
that we found that will reverse
you're doing the power to the s taking
the number to the power five
so whenever you take a number to the
power of five
if i take that result to the power 29
the result i end up with is the original
and it will always be the case on a 91
hour clock
so that's something special about 91
hour clocks and i know they're different
numbers for different clocks
that's right so it's a special property
of 5
and 29 and if you can figure out that
the number in question is
number 29 you can read the secret
messages
so it is important that no one knows the
number 29.
um so let's there's three questions we
can ask ourselves
when when we see this equation the first
one is
where did the magic number 29 come from
how do we get that
the second one is how
does the computation work why
does it reverse the operation and number
three is
is this secure why is this secure let's
answer question one
so question one is where does the magic
number 29 come from
now to see where it comes from we need
to construct a different clock
so we had a 91 hour clock which was
constructed by multiplying the two prime
numbers
7 and 13. we're going to construct the
different clock
by taking the number before the prime
number
so 6 because it's 7 minus 1 and
12 because it's 13 minus 1. multiply
them to get 72.
so we're going to work now in a 72 hour
clock
and then we're going to pick a
prime number which does not divide
72 so we're not allowed to pick two of
three because they divide 72
but 5 is allowed so let's say we pick
the number 5
that is our encryption value e
and that is the 5 that we saw before we
took 18 to the power 5. so that's an
arbitrarily chosen number to some extent
but the number 29 is not arbitrarily
chosen
because what we want to do is we want to
valid find a value d
such that e in our case 5 times
d is equal to 1 on our 72-hour clock
now finding that by computer is very
easy
it uses an algorithm called the extended
euclidean algorithm
i'm going to give you the answer because
we know what the answer is going to be
it's 29 a computer can find it quickly
and indeed if we multiply 5 times 29
what we get is 145 which is
one more than 144 and 144 is a multiple
of 72 in other words 5 times 29
is indeed equal to 1 on a 72 hour
clock and this is where that magic value
29 that we used before
comes from so that brings us then to the
second question
how does it work we came up with this
magic value
29 and and it
it has a property that five times 29
is equal to 1 on our
72 hour clock right um so what this
means
is that if we subtract 1 from 5 times 29
what we end up with is a multiple of 72.
now let me just tell you what e times d
is without any clocks
it's 145. so on a 72 hour clock
okay we go once around we go second time
around
and then we have one hour more okay
works perfectly
so if we subtract one we end up with the
number 144
so 5 times 29 minus 1 is a multiple
of 72 but that also means it's a
multiple of this number six which is
seven minus one
and it's a multiple of uh 12
which is 13 minus one so
eb minus 1 is a multiple of both
our left prime number minus 1 and our
right prime number minus 1
7 and 13 respectively now because it is
a multiple
uh of both of those numbers for each of
them individually we can
apply a theorem known as fermat's little
theorem
fermat was a famous mathematician living
hundreds of years ago
never having heard of cryptography of
course yet his results are very useful
today
so using that we can actually deduce
that
this value m to the power e d minus one
simplifies to one on our clock
now because we have this minus one we
have one little m left over
so what we end up with is one times m
which is m uh which is how it cancels
out
in the end okay so that's quite
difficult to to follow i would say
but it's quite elegant like things that
are not clear
somehow fit together as puzzle pieces
and they all cancel out and what we end
up with
is exactly our original value now
there's one remaining question
is it secure so we know that it works we
know why our magic numbers are chosen
the way they are
but the question is is is it secure so
how come
that i as in this case the university of
nottingham
am able to deduce this value d but
strangers cannot
now if we look at the way in which the
magic numbers were chosen
remember that we found the number 72 by
taking
one prime number seven subtracting one
and the other part number thirteen
subtracting one
and multiplying them how will you do
that
if you don't know the prime factors of
so you cannot find number 72 simply
because you don't know the prime factors
of 91 and
we established the very beginning that
finding prime factors was a difficult
problem
but computing a number which consists of
two prime factors
is an easy problem so the university of
nottingham came up with two 300 digit
prime numbers
multiplied them which was relatively
easy found the numbers e and d the magic
numbers
and then forgot about the prime numbers
because they are no longer relevant
and then it's secure because only people
that have the numbers p
and q will be able to deduce the secret
magic numbers and nobody else can know
the magic numbers
if i go to the site will i see those
same magic numbers
do you see what i mean so you will see
two of the three magic numbers
which is the product p times q but you
won't know what
the original values p and q were
you will see the number e which in our
little problem was in number five but
you will not see
the other magic value which in our
example was the number 29
so the number e is usually a small
number
and the number d is usually quite a
large number so that's why we found
for nottingham that the number e was 65
something but the number d which is a
secret number could really be
any number that is roughly 300 digits
long
we have no idea which number it is
you're not going to be able to search
them all
quite quickly 2 to the 16 operations 65
000 operations
even on a laptop not going to take very
long so i go through
and i find all the possible x's that
means that any device
which is keeping track of time in that
way will get
really confused and we basically get the
millennium